hello i'm jamelle johnson you may know
me from
athletic podcasting but you might not
know
i'm also a renowned art critic and i am
here in los feliz
one of los angeles whitest neighborhoods
to critique
black lives matter art i didn't go to
any official schools or art programs but
i did attend the school
of art knox let's go see how long it
takes for me to get arrested
whenever i see high quality printouts
like this i say to myself
thank goodness a white person has felt
strongly enough about my people being
shot by the police
to email a high-res photo to fedex
kinkos this next one has a bit of an
outsider art
daniel johnston-esque kind of feel
by which i mean it's bad it's pretty bad
it's very very thin very uniform lines
very tim burton
of course this building doesn't have any
signs at all but uh these little babies
are kind of hard though
the handcrafted nature of this sign
lets me know that these white people are
actually broke as [ __ ]
and maybe they didn't do that well in
high school this is a
tend to fine print you have to look very
close you have to pull out a monocle to
see if these people
really think black lives matter also
they definitely took this sign from
their restaurant job
this may just actually be a brunch menu
yeah like this is just some gang [ __ ]
but um
it's good to know the the neighborhood
still has a pulse
oh my god guys come here follow me look
at this
this is what i'm talking about this is
what we're looking for
real art apparently these white
homeowners
who benefited from systemic racism want
to dismantle it now
i can't believe what i'm saying they
also added the popular slogan acab which
stands for all cops or bastards
which is impressive because their uncle
is the chief of police
so what have we learned today
not much to be honest do black lives
matter
absolutely aside from that art is what
you make it
however you decide to show your support
for black lives just know that i don't
care about you
in the slightest art